hello and welcome to the channel once again and in today's video we are going to have a look at the
functions of the flysky fsi 6x transmitter that what is in there and what is it for so let's move
into it so here on our transmitter we have got six to ten channels if you don't watch the introductory
video please just click up in there on the i button so if we want to turn on the transmitter just simply
turn on the power button and here we have got our home screen uh this is this indicates our battery
this is our fly sky the model which we are using right now the name of the model and this is the
number of the model and here the protocol of the transmitter is work is mentioned that upon which
protocol is it working right now here we have got the voltage of the transmitter the that is 4.67
volts right now and down below when we connect it to our uh our receiver so here we get the voltage of
our receiver and the signal strength so if you want to enter the uh setup menu so just press and hold
ok for two seconds and here we enter to our menu setup so uh here are four buttons two are for the up and
down and here we have got a cancel button so if you want to quit uh uh settings so we just press the
cancel button and ok button is to enter uh settings and to save a setting we just simply have to press
and hold the cancel button for example if i just enter into the system and i just want to select a model
i want it on model 6 and i want to save it so i am just going to have press and hold the cancel button
and it is saved uh now just i just want to counter check it so press ok button it entered into it and
it is now on model 6 and it is saved and if i want i don't want to save anything i just want to quit the
same settings as it was before so if now if i change it on model 5 and i don't want to save it
i'm just going to press the cancel button once and i'm the settings will be just quit now i check it so
it was saved on model 6. so now here we have got uh two kind of setups that one is the system settings
and one is the setup so in the system settings we basically have got the model settings that which
model you want to copy a model and the receiver setups and that is actually mostly related to the
use of your transmitter the basics use and in the function and in the setup menu the functions of
the transmitter are concerned that how much will be the sensitivity which switch to use for uh which
function so now let's start from the system settings and in the system settings the first one is the
model setup the model select so in the model select we just have to select our model here are i think
so 20 models that you can have for different kind of uh airplanes or quadcopters you want so you can
select each for one i don't think so one would use all these 20 in the second one there is a model name
so if you want to name a specific model uh for a plane you want so you can do it in here for example in
the model uh for model 6 i just wanted to fly sky here here as i change it in here so with the down
button the name also changes in there and if i press ok so it changes shifts to another alphabet and if i change
one of the way as t or s so here it is and if i want to save it so press and hold cancel and here we
have got saved the um the alphabet with which we enter in there and the next one is a model name model type
that for which purpose you are using that specific model for an airplane for a helicopter or there are
many more setups i don't even use those i'm just using the airplane which works for a quadcopter and our
airplane model too the next one is a model copy so if you want the settings of one model into another
so you just use the settings uh if you just set model 5 for example for an airplane and if you are
making another airplane and you want the settings of model 5 to be there in model 6 so you just use
this function the next one is the model reset if you want to reset a model for example i want to reset
the model 6 which i which i just renamed right now so i press ok and it asks for uh permission i'm going to
press yes and press ok button and the model will be reset now if i enter into it so the name is again reset
to its default uh name the next one is the rx setup that is actually related to your receiver setup that
what your receiver uh setups will be so the first one is the rf standard which means that on which protocol you want your
receiver to work for example i'm just using this receiver the flysky fsia6b which works on the protocol
of the afhds2a you also have some receivers which are working on the protocol of afhds for example i have
got this receiver uh which works on the protocol of afhds so uh here we have to mention that which
protocol you want to use the next one is the rx battery that uh on which voltage you want an alarm
and on which you want a high setup so uh you just set it from here you also have the option to select
an external sensor which is i think attached in here i don't know i never used it the next one is the
failsafe in the failsafe in the failsafe you just uh tell your receiver that what to do upon failsafe if
it disconnects from your transmitter so for example i just want channel 3 to be set up on a failsafe i
first uh enter into channel 3 i put uh i just press the uh up button to turn it on and the position i want
channel 3 to be upon failsafe that for example i want channel 3 my throttle to be on 50 percent upon the
failsafe so i put my throttle on 50 percent and press and hold the cancel button so now it is on zero which
means that uh my here my throttle is minus 50 percent here is zero and here it will be uh 100 so that is
upon zero in the middle and uh my throttle will be on zero or if i just uh get a feel safe some somewhere
the next one is the sensor list in which we get a list of the sensors that which sensors are there and
for example right now we just have a sensor which tells us the internal voltage of our transmitter we also
have the receiver uh voltage when it is connected to the esc so uh you have the option to connect some
other sensors so you will just get it here listed the next one is two sensors you can have three sensors
connected to it i think somehow some sometimes you need uh altitude sensor or i never use that so i don't
know too much about this but it is actually for the sensors use the next one is the speed distance that
you want to use a speed sensor a rotation length or there are some kind of auto meter device which are
used for the measurement of the speed so if you have connected that one to it so you'll get a data of that one in here
you can just select and set up from here the next one is the esl pressure which means above sea level pressure
that is actually used for an altitude sensor you just have to calibrate the pressure uh that upon which
the zero position of the altitude sensor must be so here you put the value in and that works according to
this the next one is the output mode that upon which more you want your receiver to work that is actually
too much important because sometimes you use a ppm input sometimes you use a pwm output of this receiver
sometimes you use it in ibis or espus so you just set it in here so the next one is our ibis setup that
our ibis setup which will be on which of the uh receive receiver port on here so we just set it on here
the next one is the server frequency that how much times you want the server to get input each second
actually frequency means that so uh you want to calibrate or set this value according to your
server manufacturers give you or you can just put it on 50. uh i never got a problem um regarding this setup
so that was that was all about the setup menu and now we will move to the function setup so in the
function setup the first one is the reverse reverse means to reverse a channel the the movement of the
channel uh for example i want this stick to uh to pitch down when i move it downwards so uh and and it
moves upwards so i just reversed the channel on which this stick is this stick is i think so on channel
three no no channel four so i don't actually remember that but you just have to reverse that channel
that specific channel which you want to to move on the opposite side so the next next one is the display
settings i want the display to tell you first and then i'll come to the end points so in the display
settings you get a display of your moments for example i am moving the aileron here we have got moment of
channel one here we have got the channel three movement which is a throttle so always when you move
something you have got a display of that in the display menu so when we move to the end points in the
end points you actually have got the limit of your moment of a specific channel for example i've got my
aileron on channel one and i want its throw to be more the throw is actually the moment the area of the
moment of your control surface so i want the aileron to move more so i will increase it up to 120 that is the
highest limit so in the display actually your uh upon your full moment of your stick it moves up up
up till this line but when i want i set it on uh limit up till the 120 then upon the full stick it goes to
here up till the end so that is the most like on this side it was 100 so it will move up till this line
and the side which was moved to 120 it moves up till the extreme position so that is actually that is
actually the end point the next one is the aux channels that which are which channel which switch
you want on which channel for example for channel 5 i want the uh switch a to be working switch a that is
actually mentioned here so i'll just change it to switch a and i'll press and hold cancel button the next
one is the subtrim subtrim is actually the settings of your uh control setting that is actually the tuning
of your aircraft for example your rudder or your specific control surface is not aligned so you can just
align it here on the sub trim settings that your control sticks will be moved without uh holding your
control sticks so it is that kind of setup the do the next one is the dual rate and exponential settings
which is actually the the the sensitivity of your controls i'm going to explain it in detail in a
later video the next one is a throttle curve it actually means that how much your throttle increase
upon this movement like for example you want your throttle to be less uh increasing from 0 to 25
so you actually increase decrease the value of 25 and the graph will change so it will move
from here to 0.1 your throttle will be increasing less and then your throttle will have more ratio of increase
the next one is the mixer setup and mixer setup you actually make one channel the
the master and any other the slave and if you want for example there is a phenomenon called uh adverse heel
and you want uh your rudder to move automatically upon rolling so you just set the master channel one which is
your aileron and the slave as channel two which is your channel four which is your rudder so that will move
accordingly the next one is the le one if you want an le one setup of an aircraft you just get it from here the next one is the
retail which is also a an aircraft setup so if you want an aircraft to be set up as a a retail aircraft so you set up at
set it set it up from here the next option is the assigned switches which means that which switch to assign for which purpose for example i want
switch a to be functioning as a throttle hold switch so i select switch a here and i press and hold cancel
and when i see here so upon switch a i turn in off the throttle hold function so the next one is a throttle hold and in throttle hold actually we have a
a functionality or a control over our throttle that if we activate it so our throttle will be
at the specific position we want for example upon activation of the throttle hold uh function i want
my throttle to be at 50 percent or at 60 percent so i want i will set it x at 60 percent and i'll press and
hold cancel button to save it so now if i go to the display settings and i want to see its functionality so upon
activating the throttles which for example my throttle is at zero right now and if i activate it so my
throttle would actually automatically move to 60 percent even if i move at my throttle right now it will not
move from its its location which we set in the settings that is 60 percent and if i just deactivate it
so even we can move that again okay so that was all about the flysky fsi 6x transmitter functions if you
like the video please like share and subscribe to the channel and if i miss something please tell me
down in the comments thank you and see you